The African promised land.
From the window of the high-speed train
that connects Cape Town to Tunis you can see
the wonders of the richest
continent on Earth, which is powering the global economy.
You immediately passed the best
universities in the world where the
global elite compete to send their
children. Passing through Zimbabwe the
vast acres of fertile farmland that are
the breadbasket of the southern
hemisphere are breathtaking.
As you travel through the Congo the machinery of the nationalised mining industry
marks the horizon. Lagos greets you with
the warmest of welcomes, a bustling
metropolis that knows no poverty. As you
cross the Sahara Desert you cannot take
your eyes of the vast expanse of solar
panels that blanket the terrain.
In Tunis you arrive at one of the
busiest border control checkpoints in
the world, as thousands of people each
day try to migrate into Africa for work
and opportunity. The contrast of your
journey could not be starker. You have
just covered thousands of miles with a
passport. Colonial borders were long ago
abandoned and the continent is unified
into a shared economic and political
vision. All of this is only possible
because Africa is able to control her
resources free from the interference of
the West, whose role was to impoverish
and underdeveloped the continent first
through slavery, then colonialism and
finally unfair trade practices. Corrupt,
puppet African leaders who siphoned off
wealth in offshore banks and spent
lavishly in European department stores
were deposed and governments made
accountable to the people.
Rejecting Western development aid meant being free
from the despotic economic control of
the World Bank and International
Monetary Fund. No more debt repayments,
forced austerity or flooding of
African markets with Western produce.
Africa never needed Western pity or
foreign charities being paid to build
wells, send blankets or provide malaria
relief. Donating a tiny fraction of the
money exploited from the continent may
have ease collective Western guilt but
it did nothing to change the fact that
the West was the problem in Africa.
It was only by removing the claws that dug
so deep and extracted so much for
centuries that Africa could prosper.
Memories of a time where millions of
children died each year because of poor
access to food feel like a distant
nightmare. Monuments to those who lost
their lives crossing the Sahara Desert
or drowning on makeshift boats in the
Mediterranean are the only reminder of
the devastating poverty that plagued the
continent and caused so many to flee.
Instead Africa offers an escape to those
in the Diaspora trapped in the West
facing racism, poverty and criminal
injustice. They are invited to complete
the historical circle
and return to the African Promised Land.